hi everybody my name is Winston Chang
I'm a software engineer at our studio
and today I'm going to be talking about
doing interactive graphics with SHINee
there are a bunch of code examples which
you can see at this URL at the bottom on
github and the end the slides are
available there too okay
so here's a little review of what I'm
going to talk about today so first I'm
going to talk about different kinds of
graphics and what we'd use them for so
so there are static versus interactive
graphics static graphics are you know
traditional plots that you would see
might print them out now you can't
interact with them and interactive ones
obviously are things that you can
interact with by using your mouse
there are graphics for different
purposes so for example you might have a
graphic for presentation like if you're
creating a report that you want to
display to somebody or for publication
and there's data graphics for exploring
your data so if you're still in the data
analysis process or you know index you
know exploratory data analysis phase and
what you're trying to learn something
about your data that's that's another
purpose reading a data graphic as
opposed to for presentation so after
that I'm going to talk about the nuts
and bolts of actually creating an
interactive graphics with shiny so we'll
get into some code and after that I'm
going to talk about using creating shiny
gadgets which are those are it's using
shiny for the data exploration phase and
this is a new feature that we've added
in China 0.13 which was released a month
ago oh and I should also mention that
the interactive graphics features were
added in the last year okay so if when
we're thinking about data graphics one
question that well one issue is
important when thinking open is is a
graphic static or is it interactive
so here are a bunch of static graphics
these are all generated by our they
should all be probably all looks
familiar to you
some one of the most basic things we do
in our is to create to create
visualizations like this so up here we
have a histogram created by the his
tongue ssin here we have a scatterplot
created by the plot function with a well
this one actually helps it has a linear
regression a line edit as well and then
over here we have a box plot and these
these graphics and our these are all
part of the base our package and they're
all here I mean they're all they're all
static it's sort of the way that things
evolve you know before before our
existed these types of graphics existed
and they were targeted towards probably
mostly towards print publication or
printing out creating printouts for
reports and you know back a long time
ago people drew these out by hand and
then after once computers came around
and were able to generate some of these
they were they could generate these
figures but they were still meant for
printing on paper and they tended to not
have a lot of interactive features so
that sort of be the heritage of of these
types of plots so more recently this is
not like really recent history but more
recently there have been interactive
graphical systems like this this is a
screenshot this is actually two
screenshots of of a program called G gob
which allows one to interact with the
data and explore it so all of these
these plots are linked in this example
this is not a live example this is a
screenshot but it lets you take a look
at the subset of this data so like with
this yellow highlighted region the data
here corresponds to the highlighted bits
here and B scatter plots and in these
bars here and and then in the second
plot on the right or the second set of
plots on the right there's a larger
region that's selected here and the
other corresponding points are
highlighted so this sort of tool was
used for designed for data exploration
and still trying to learn something
about your data but it's not targeted
toward presentation for you know for
obviously you know you can't use this
for print output because you're not
going to be able to interact with a
printed page and and but even on you
know even sharing this over a computer
is difficult because other people might
not have the software and the software
to run the same sort of visualization
that you've created here okay so a
second questions have hinted out already
is what is the purpose of the graphic so
for data graphic you might use them for
in the exploratory phase of your data
analysis so here's an example I'm
looking at this histogram of the built
in data set in our about geyser
eruptions Old Faithful
so I run histogram here it looks like
this and I decide well what if I want to
look at a histogram a little bit more
detail with smaller bin size well I can
just tweak a parameter and and then it
looks like this so I've run hist again
with a greater number of breaks or
greater number of bins in other words
and and then it looks like this and you
know by tweaking these parameters during
the data exploration phase you might be
able to learn something new about the
data but these you know it's not these
are not all meant to be shared with
other people this might just this is
just for me to learn something about the
data okay and then once you're done
doing your data exploration and learning
about your data and processing it you
might generate data graphics for
presentation so this is just a page out
of a book it's got these line graphs and
these are meant for you know this isn't
meant for the data analyst or the
researcher to learn about the data this
is meant to communicate some findings to
readers in this case readers of a book
so it could be you know print a print
article or just you know a report
printed report
or something that's on a webpage
dashboard perhaps hmm okay so status
data graphics about five years ago was
that well you can generate there's tools
for generating static graphics or data
exploration phase and this is a
screenshot of that we sell before but
there's plenty of other tools I mean
even you know Excel can generate static
graphics that you can use for data
exploration those same graphics once you
finish your data analysis they could be
used for presentation maybe a tweak them
to look a little bit nicer but they're
essentially the same thing and for for
the data exploration phase there were
interactive tools like G goby which are
good for learning something about your
data but it's more difficulties them too
for presentation to communicate those
findings telling people for for mostly
for technical reasons but this left us
but so there's this quadrant other
quadrant here that was sort of left
unfilled so interactive graphics for
presentation well in the last few years
that's changed quite a bit so here are
some examples from near times these are
examples of data journalism they do a
really good job with these so here's the
rivers - screenshot I'll show you these
live the web browser up here okay
so here's an interactive tax text well
explore like are you receiving the
marriage panel to your bonus so the idea
is that in the United States if you file
your taxes as a married couple jointly
versus filing separately as two single
people you may end up paying more in
taxes or less if you're even if you've
had the same amount of income
so for example you know so I just pick
this number up here if you're you're
part of a couple and you earn eighty one
thousand dollars here and all of that is
earned by one partner and the other
partner doesn't have any income then
then if you file as a married couple
then you save we pay five thousand three
hundred dollars less in taxes so whereas
if you're up here where you know both
partners and about the same amount and
then then if you file as a married
couple then you actually pay more in
taxes than you would if you filed single
so so this this graphic has some basic
interactive features you know you can
you can hover over it and it will tell
you some information so if you want to
find out like yeah I'm a cuddler couple
and you know one person makes this much
money the other Christian makes it the
so the amount of money you can get some
detailed information about how much of a
bonus or penalty your pain in Texas and
that's something that you know that it
adds a lot to this graphic if you just
if you just see this graphic like this
you know a lot of it information is
there
but it's a little bit harder to
interpret and it's it's it's it's harder
to find yourself on here like with these
these various incomes like on this on
the x-axis here the total income in the
y-axis is the percentage split that's
but earned by each partner okay so
that's one example another example is
this this interactive map here this is
about well the best and worst places to
grow up so if you are that idea behind
this one is if you depending on where
you grew up and your income percentile
there are some places where it's where
if you grow up as an adult you'll tend
to earn more money or you'll tender and
less money based on we grow up compared
to other places one nation so I live in
in Minnesota in Minneapolis so just a
zoom in on that
as you can see well actually let me back
up for a sec so you see this large map
here there's all this information here
so there's some parts of the nation
where people tend to earn more money
when they grow up and some people were
the places where the tender and less so
I I live up here Upper Midwest so I
guess people tend to earn more money as
they grow when they grow up here but
it's again it's a little bit hard to
interpret that information just by
looking at this map so the interactive
features that this supports is zooming
and then when i zoom in enough I can see
some value I can see some numbers here
so there's a $700 bonus if you grow up
in Hennepin County where I live and are
in the 21st 2015 come percentile and
when I hover over it each one it gives
you a little bit more sort of a detailed
text box that gives information but some
of the same information ok but this lets
you you know this looks this interactive
map really lets people learn a lot more
about the data than they would otherwise
be able to just by looking at just by
looking at the zoomed out map okay so
that's again that's something that's
pretty new that that people are able to
do now which is creating these these
interactive graphics for presentation
and in journalism dator data journalism
examples are good examples of
presentation ok so here we filled in the
all these boxes here now we've got so
for interactive graphic videos for
presentation there are the technologies
to do that today so the things that have
changed that Nathan made that possible
are well there's there's two really big
changes so one of them is that there's
fast networks for sharing visualizations
right these are not there's nothing that
you can share imprints can't we can't
publish interactive graphics to your
book and expect them to be still be
interactive so and this is you know the
tool the the technology that is made as
possible is in
the other change is that there's
widespread standardized technologies for
that people interact with and these are
web browsers so web browsers are
everywhere they're on your phone their
own computers on everybody's desk and
you know web browsers also existed for a
while just what the Internet has but
it's only been recently we're different
a lot of JavaScript libraries for data
visualization that can bring both
interactive graphics to people and it
makes me to use wage and again that's
that's something that's really changed a
lot in the last in the last five years
okay so we've got the same matrix here
but this time I'm sort of looking at a
slightly different aspect of it and what
this is showing is what tools can you
use to create these things so up here
for static graphics for both exploration
and presentation you can use R and with
an asterisk here that asterisk down the
bottom I say book so I'm so this is our
and data visualization packages like
ggplot2 and lattice and a host of other
ones as well so just some of the more
popular ones so are asterisk those
capable of creating static graphics for
book exploration and presentation now
for interactive graphics that was harder
to do but previously but now you can use
that same knowledge that you have of R
and an add some knowledge of shiny and
create interactive graphics for both
exploration and for presentation so
probably most of the example that you've
seen most of a shining example that
you've seen are meant for presentation
they're meant to be delivered over the
web for people to you know for the data
analysts creates this and somebody else
is consuming the information
so here's here's here's a really basic
example of of that so this is a well
this is probably a most basic example
that we have of a shiny application so
this is an interactive graphic where the
graphic shows us histogram I would same
data that we saw before but there's a
slider that can control the number of
bins that are shown in the histogram or
the number of bars this is not a live
app so I'll show you the actual thing by
running this code in our studio okay
okay here we go so I move the slider
that histogram updates but and this is
you know from the very beginning shining
is able to do this it had these sort of
web form like inputs this is a slider
which is a little bit more advanced in a
typical web form input but there's also
select inputs and text inputs people
could enter in numbers and those would
influence those could influence how this
plot is displayed but but this graphic
itself is not interactive so if I click
and drag on it what it's you can see
it's just like I could save this to a
file but I can't actually interact with
this bar okay now let me go into the
code in a little bit of detail here
probably few views training before this
should all be very familiar but if
you're new to shiny then then you might
learn something from this so there's two
parts of the UI code and there's your
server code so in the UI I define the
layout so I say it's a basic page
there's a plot output that defines a
container for this plot to go in that's
called an occultist with a name clot and
a slider input with the name bins and a
bunch of other parameters like the
minimum and maximum and a label for it
so that's that defines it that that
tells China they should get slider input
here okay so that's the UI side that's
what shows up in the web that's what the
web browser receives it's actually just
it is an HTM
webpage on the server side there is this
is code that executes in an hour process
on the server and I tell if there's an
output called plot output dollar plot
and what should be displayed there is
the histogram
it's a histogram of the data set
faithful dollar waiting and the break
that's the number of Bin's
is taken from input dollar bins so
that's been put here slider input called
bins and that matches up with the input
dollar bins output dollar plot that
matches up with this plot output plot
okay so that's how it all gets tied
together just put on the server side
with its input and output these input
and output values okay so alright so
that's that's like a basic shiny app
that's stuff that we've always been able
to do in shiny now the new part is these
directing reactions with plots so let me
show you an example okay so with that
histogram that we saw I couldn't do
anything I couldn't click or drag on it
or anything like that with this with the
scatter plot here I can click on it and
as you can see there's these X&Y files
that show up in the bottom there that
correspond to where I clicked so let's
say I want to click at five comma or x
value of five and the y value at 15
that's about right and you can see
that's that's what that's what displayed
down here so this is something that
this is something that being able to
click on a plot like this now these raw
values might not be so useful on their
own but I'll show you to do with them in
a little bit okay let's look at the code
so it's really simple it's it's uh it's
very simple to use so with what we have
now is a plot output with the plot and
now I say click equals plot underscore
click so it's the same as your regular
plot output except you just add this new
thing click this plot underscore click
that defines a new input value called
plot limit or click and it has X&Y
positions so here I have the render plot
and out here this is the this is the
text I'm generating the text for the X
in that displays the X&Y position
alright and it's just input $1 plot
click dollar x and y that's all there is
to it but that in it of itself as I
mentioned might not be super useful
because you know usually don't just want
the raw coordinate let's run this again
usually don't just want the raw
coordinate you want to do something with
it like for example select the nearest
point alright so in order to do that
there's a function called near points
now demonstrate how this I'll
demonstrate this in action and I'll talk
about the code so now if I click near
point it pulled up what I'm displaying
down here is it pulled out a row of data
from the data set and it's actually
because my line wrapping here is a
little bit the line wrap column a little
bit narrow it's displaying on two rows
but this is this is one row out of a
data frame with all these different
columns so I click near this point it
displays that if I click far away it's
not going to it doesn't display anything
has to be within 5 pixels but that's the
value that I've chosen here
code for that looks like this so so for
the input or the output dollar info a
render print and to select a row I use
near points with new function near
points I give it the data object empty
cars the the click input which is input
data plot quick and then I tell out
which columns out of empty cars I'm
using for my X and y axis so weight or
WT and mpg and and like I said it
there's a well it has to be within five
pixels off the value of chosen the the
click history within five pixels of a
point and the maximum number point it
will select is one that's the maximum
number of rows it will return from the
from that data so and I'll just other
than straight that briefly so so I'm
clicking right here there's actually a
bunch of there's actually two points
right here that are very close but
because I've said the maximum number of
points is one it will only return one
rare out of the data which is being
displayed down there if I change that
max rose to something else I could I
could have returned more more rows okay
now another thing to note is that I did
that plot with base our graphics if
you're using ggplot2 you don't need to
pass in the X variable and the y
variable names because those are shiny
knows enough about ggplot2 objects we
will extract that information
automatically okay now another thing you
might want to do with that so that's
that's one use of the click information
is to select the nearest point yeah
another thing you can do is to add a
point to to a plot or to a data set so
it's actually you know I should talk
about this code first before I
demonstrate it so one thing you might
one way you might do that you might
approach it is by using our bind so so
in this is an example I'm just taking
empty cars and pulling out the two
columns I'm interested in weight and mpg
and then I say if
the input dollar plot click is not null
so if there's some if there is a click
somebody had clicked on something then
our bind a new road to that data frame
with X&Y positions and then plot that
okay so this is this is the first pass
approach at this and if I were to run
this now this might not come out very
well in this this webinar but if I click
on this you can see a point appears
briefly and then it disappears so well
why is that that's kind of weird that's
not very useful I'm not actually adding
a point to my data well maybe I am but
it only lasts for a moment well we can
take a look at this code the problem is
is that when I click it sets this input
that would clock click to a non null
value so it that tells this whole render
plot to re execute and then it enters
into this if statement and it R binds
the data successfully and it plots it so
we do see that point for a moment but
then when the plot is up the updated
plot is sent to the web browser for
display this value for input dollar
clock quick get strict set and when that
gets reset went because the value
changed and that's hell's the render
plot to re execute when we execute this
time plot underscore clickers no and and
it doesn't enter in this if statement
and just plots empty like the empty car
resort right any modification so so so
we have an issue with reactivity here
that we have to deal with so the way to
deal with that is something that I call
state like emulation so this combination
of using a reactive values object and of
the observer event function so this is a
little bit more advanced but this is if
you're if you're doing if you're doing
interactive graphics where you need to
record a bunch of events that happen
like a bunch of changes that people make
to it like clicking on cooking on a plot
you need to you need to save that
information somehow and store it and
build it up and so this is this is a
common way that you would do it so if a
combination of reactive values so here I
create something called
it's a reactive values object that is
similar to the the input object actually
of a shiny application it isn't it's the
same type of object so and there's an
item in it called MTC
so when MTC changes you have valves
Delta MTC I'll similar to when an input
value changes that will tell any
reactive that use that to reacts acute
so we don't afford about the details
right now about how that works but um so
we're del vallès our MTC and then we say
observe event when input Dali plot click
changes that's what this means a live
event input that o'clock click means
when this change is execute this code
and what this code does is the our bind
the existing value of MTC and then adds
a new a new row on to that with X&Y
positions will click and then for a plot
it's very simple we just we just plot
this valve our MTC dollar weight and mpg
so if we run this code there we go and
now when I click any point gets added so
that this may be useful as well for
experimenting with what would happen if
a data point was added here like how
would how would a model fit of this
change for example so yeah so there you
go
all right now this is something that
I'll get back to we talk about gadgets
but it's useful to know right now so you
can have a shiny app normally when you
deploy a shiny app to a remote server
you don't want the app to exit and
return about it that led in useful that
just quit in somebody's web browser but
if you're running it locally you can
actually interact with a shiny app
perhaps with an interactive graphic and
then have it return some value like like
for example when I was adding those
points you could have it return all the
data frame containing all burning points
and to do that you would add an action
button called done or call it whatever
you want but the just an action button
and then have a server vent that's
listening on input dollar done and when
somebody clicks on that button called
stop app I know it turns or returns the
value here so when you run your shiny
app at the at the at the arc console
you'd say run app give the app and then
save the return value into a variable
and that will that will take when the
app stops returns valves onpc and that
gets saved into value into this variable
called value okay but we'll come back to
that when we talked about gadgets so
some other interactions that was just I
showed you clicking there's some other
ones that are useful as well there's a
well as clicking there's double clicking
and you can see the way that I use the
click option before is I said click
equals the string plot underscore quick
that's actually equivalent to running
this one click equals click off ID
equals plot underscore click this is
just a shorthand the one that we use so
in this double click I've written out in
a long way and the reason that the long
form is useful because you can pass
other options to it so there's also
hovering which is when your mouse moves
and rests over a location you can send
that coordinate to the server so here in
this case if I hover equals hover
let's give the ID and then I set this
option delay can 500 so my mouse has to
rest some over a plot for half a second
500 milliseconds before it sends a
updated value to the server
okay so I'll demonstrate these okay here
okay all right so here is my scatter
plot and you could actually see that
plot this input value plot hover it
updates when I move the mouse you slow
down a little bit so you can see a
little bit more of that so right now I'm
showing you the entire data structure
that's sent from the browser to to the
r-process so normally I just access X&Y
but those are the top two things but
there's all this other information that
you can use as well and if you need if
you want to explore this information you
can you can just run str on these on
these input values and and it will it'll
display this so again the hovering
updates when I rest my mouse for a
moment clicking I just click the mouse
click it again about updates when I
click double click I double click there
may be a double click okay so you can
use these values for we can use these
different interactions for different
purposes and there's another type of
interaction that's really useful it's
called Russian so I can select a region
I just click my mouse and dragged it and
this time instead of just x and y it's
actually giving the xmin and xmax you
know this x range and the y-min and
y-max in the wide range of this you can
you can drag this around as well Pecos
values you can you can resize it and it
should be pretty obvious this is this
can be useful for if you want to select
a bunch of points you know or let's say
you want to exclude some points because
they're outliers and you can you do it
for it use it for that as well ok so now
let me show you how the brushing works
it's pretty simple like the clicking
it's you just add a new option brush
equals plat underscore brush and if you
want to see the points or the rows of
data or the points that we're so one
that were selected in the brush you'd
say we have a sub a function like in
your points hold brushed point you say
brush points give the data object empty
cars and then give it the brush input so
input dollar-plus brush that corresponds
with this here all right so that's
pretty simple and I'll demonstrate this
there we go okay okay so here's a plot
right now there's zeros are selected so
I just brush over those points you can
see there's three rows are selected
again this I got this funny wrapping
here so there's three rows that are
selected I can move it over to here and
uh one two three four five six seven
eight points are selected and it's just
it's printing these out and you could
take these points and do something on
them right you could you could hide them
or you could include them in a linear
model or exclude X clipping familiar
model and so on that brush points
function makes it really simple to
figure out which ones are better
selected which so that's that's one
that's one use for for brushing oh and
there's some other options for
depression if you've worked with
interactive graphics or you've designed
interactive graphics before you might
know the difference between game
balancing and throttling you can control
it here and if you're running if you
know you're running your application
locally as opposed to filter it over you
know serving it up across the internet
then you can reduce the delay before
that the brush has to rest before it
sends ursins an update to the server and
you can make it if you're running a
locally connected motor sponsored by
reducing that values so this is this
would update it for 30 milliseconds so
that's very fast
okay so alright so that's now another
technique that you can use by taking
these plot interactions is to link plots
so in the previous stuff I just showed
you
here's how to select data points out of
a select out of your here's how to
select data points that were cliff
Donner or brushed but we can actually
link to plots ago let me demonstrate an
example of that okay so here I have two
plots and they're connected the their
these are both scatter plots of the same
data set but they're there this one is
plotting the HP and disc column and this
one is plotting the mpg and wait column
of empty cars now if I select a bunch of
points with brush with a brush it'll
highlight them in that second plot there
turns in blue
alright so this can this can be useful
for finding connections between variable
from the data there's going to be some
general trend Azuri of you know these
points are not when I select a group
here if not simply a random group that's
shown the second plotters there's some
some connection between these variables
okay so now in this particular example I
don't have the it's not possible to
brush in the second spot and have it
update the first plot that's that's a
bit more code so I'm just trying to keep
it simple for right now sorry so how
does this how do we do this well in the
UI side we create to plot output
sometimes called scatter one once called
scatter - the first one has we give it
the brush option or the brush parameter
and we just get a brush and on the
server side to generate the first plot
we just say render plot and DG plot with
some points so the code to create a
scatter plot and for the second one we
do a little bit more we
first we find we take the brushed points
from empty cars of the input della brush
you'll notice that this one is using GD
plot too so I didn't have to specify the
x and y variables I just gave it the
data object and the brush so it's very
very easy to call this and I save that
in a variable called brushed and then I
do a GG plot of of the dataset and add a
layer of points this is the base layer
points and then I also add another layer
of points given with just the brushed
data points so if a data equals brushed
and then I give it a different color to
highlight them so so that's all it takes
to to link those plots together that way
again but this is this is one
directional linking or one you have one
directional wing depression okay
another another useful technique is
linked to the zooming so this is a I'll
show you an example of this okay this is
the line graph well it's actually two
line graphs of sunspot data going all
the way back to about 1750 from from
about 1750 to probably about 1990 or so
now this is this is a time series and
this link brushing is a common kind of
use thing in the time series you may
have seen this like in the stock charts
for example what I can do is I can
they're showing the same data right now
but I can select a region on the bottom
here so I'm using the brush here in just
a horizontal direction and then it
displays that subset of data that's
brushed up here on top and this first
plot so that lets me look at this with a
lot more a lot more detail and if this
graph wasn't interactive it would be
much more difficult I mean you could do
this in R but you'd have to just from a
console by plotting it and zooming in on
regions but it would be a lot more
tedious work than it takes to just drag
the brush over like that
okay if I click outside and the brush
disappears and that resets the source
plot okay the way that to do this is
I've created to plot outputs and for the
second one I say brush equals brush opt
ID equals brush and I give it I tell it
only brush in the x-direction so
previously you're able to brush in the x
and y directions by dragging a rectangle
this time you just drag horizontally and
it selects the whole vertical region
automatically writer it displays with
something in the whole vertical region
right so I'm just moving my mouse
horizontally and that whole vertical
region is selected okay now server side
for the zoomed in plot I just say well
so I've got my ggplot defined up here
for the zoomed in plot I just say if the
brush input dot would brush does not
know then take that plot which I saved
in P and set the X limit so that's
basically setting the X range for it to
the input dollar brush so x-min and
x-max and this is with ggplot2 that lets
the syntax with base graphics it's and
it's it's similar it's a little bit of
different but it's similar so just add
that on there with ggplot and then and
then the trim plot and that's all it
takes
okay close that moving on okay so the
next big topic that i want to talk about
is shiny gadgets so the stuff that we've
seen like most shiny apps that you see
in the gallery are those are shiny apps
that are they obviously have some
interactive features and whether the
graphics themselves are interactive is
you know sort of a separate question but
those are often meant for presentation
so for presenting something intellectual
and something interesting over the web
for somebody else now some of these can
be used for data exploration right if
you're if you are a if your data analyst
you might create a tool for for other
people to explore a data set and so so
the line there's not necessarily a sharp
line between data presentation and data
exploration but um but there is sort of
a gradual a gradation between that but
now shiny gadgets these are things that
are meant explicitly for the data
exploration phase they're meant for part
of when you're doing your data analysis
mirror when you're learning about it
and you want to use some interactive
graphical tools for for explore data
that's what shiny gadgets are for and
this is something that was previously
not very easy to do in our but hopefully
this turn of gadgets we're making a lot
easier so the new in shiny 0.13 which
was released in January and yes again
they make it easy to using retro
graphics for an exploration phase okay
so let me demonstrate a simple now this
first one I'm going to show you is
actually not interactive graphics it's a
very simple gadget and it's it's it's
useful to see this before we did with a
graphical part to understand what's
what's going on so this is an a gadget
that asks prompt somebody to type in
their password now this this can be
useful because in our well if you have
them type in their password in a
function call it could be save it in the
our history so I got my nurse to do any
of your history tab here and it can show
you everything that you've typed and you
don't want passwords to be in there
probably so I say I typed in my password
ABC puts done and you can see it return
this value ABC so I can say I want to
save that in something called a variable
called PW type a password ABC being done
and then if I take PW it'll kind of that
value so so I've got the password saved
in that variable
so that's what a shiny gadget is it runs
in the it runs in this little viewer
window here there's our there's all the
display modes for it in our studio if
you're not using our studio it'll pop up
in a web browser but it will have the
same functionality and definites it's a
nice little interactive tool right here
that uses shiny but this was not meant
for deployment right you wouldn't you
wouldn't deploy this on a website and
what using shiny server or shiniest at
i/o and you won't want people to click
the done button and then have the app
exit because you know that's that's not
useful that just that would just go a
wrap on the server okay so there's a so
there's three main differences in how
shiny gadgets operate compared to
regular shiny apps so the first is that
you invoke it from a function so I call
that function get underscore password
and that function it runs a special
shiny app the special shiny app has it
uses mini UI for the layout it's the new
package that we released along with
shining 0.13 and it's meant especially
for laying out shiny gadgets or other
other applications in the small country
into the constrained space hence the
name mini UI and finally when that exits
are sorry when somebody clicks on the
done button they call stop app and and
that ends that happen it returns values
to the our console okay so let's see ok
I'll explain the features here so first
as I said it's invoked from our function
get password so define this function
here get password it's a function that
does all this stuff it finds a UI server
and then it calls run gadget okay that's
the special function for for doing
gadgets so when they call when the user
runs get password it it runs all this
code and culture on gadget
and hopefully you know if you're making
gadgets for other people to use
they just load this it could be in a
package for example they just have this
function and they all they don't need to
know all the internals of it is called
get password so for the layout this this
stuff is from mini UI so there's this
function mini page gadget title bar and
mini content panel I'll show how I'll
show you how those line up in a little
bit and finally we have this observer
event in put dollars done so when they
click on the done button it stops the
app and returns that input dollar
password or if they have a cancel button
then it it stops and so it's no password
that's and this is those are things the
gadget title bar automatically has those
cancel and dumb buttons she'd open to
you okay so now here's an example of a
gadget with interactive graphics all
right I'll run this application it was
gadget okay now the inspiration from
that for this one was I was talking to a
friend of mine who's a statistician and
he he was showing me something that he
had to do in order to exclude outliers
from a data set so if you had a scatter
plot like this and the way that he would
do it is he used are most of the time so
he would save his data out of our open
it up loaded up in Minitab and then
Minitab has a little graphical saying
for excluding outliers from the data set
suite excluded points fever is all out
of Minitab and then import it back into
our and that was just a pain so he
showed me this and I'm like okay well I
think we can we can do something that's
a lot better we can keep it all in our
and give it a nice interface so scatter
plot of that data set and now if I click
on these points you can see I'm
excluding them from what's being used in
this linear model
and I can I can brush points I can turn
those on back on I can hide these ones
and remove those ones from this from the
model calculation and I can also change
the model the polynomial degree used in
the model so this is a quadratic one
I'll turn those points back on or can
use a cubic and so on so anyway so let's
say I toggle some of these points again
I do degree two and then I say I'm done
well okay let's get that console back so
you can see it see the result here so I
ran it LM gadget that was my function
that's the name of the function that
runs that gadget I save that output in a
variable called M and I just happened
the way that I wrote this gadget it
returns the data of all the selected
data points all the ones that were not
excluded and it also returns the model
object that's an LM object and you know
it's got the coefficients polynomial
degree two so it's got the those two
coefficients as well okay so that's so
with this type of gadget you can you can
use all for your analysis you know for
all the great things that are is great
for for all the stuff that you can run
with code at the command line but you
can also use it for those times where
you need a graphical interaction okay
so now as I mentioned before I'll
explain how these things these functions
line up to the UI function went up to
various parts of the interface so I
called mini page that defines this whole
page here I say a gadget title bar and
that creates a title bar that goes
across the top here and give it I give
it the name interactive LM which is
printed up there there's a cancel and a
done button that are added automatically
and then I add a mini contents panel
that's where the basic or the main
content goes and then at the bottom I
had a mini button block which is it's
it's a fixed height thing at the bottom
that I can add bones to you I have the
two buttons but you can add more or
fewer if you like and if you've worked
up with layups and with regular shiny
code or you know in HTML and CSS in
general you know that it's hard to keep
a fixed height thing it can be hard to
keep fixed type things at the bottom and
to have the height of a container scale
to the available size but the mini UI
package takes care of that all that for
you so that's that's that's the reason
it's there mmm okay this is the code
what is the code that I use to
accumulate the state when somebody
clicks on a point or toggle them with
the brush but I think are running short
of time so I won't go into detail on
this okay so to wrap up I well or talked
about static graphics versus interactive
graphics talked about using graphics for
presentation as opposed to exploration
and hopefully you'll be able to take
what you know about our and we already
know about our and creating plots and
our and add this bit of shiny knowledge
and you'll be able to create you know
you go we'll fill in all four quadrants
of that about matrix that that I showed
you earlier
there's some other here's some resources
that show you how to do these things
there's the the article section of the
SHINee Dev Center so it's at this URL
and there's two if you're going on that
page there's two sections that are
relevant there's the interactive plot
section and there's the shiny gadgets
section and in the gallery there's the
there are interactive plots that there
toward the bottom but there's not a
shiny gadgets section in the gallery the
gallery actually runs live apps and so
since China gadgets are not meant to be
delivered over the web they meant to run
in your local hour session there's it
wouldn't make sense to put them in in
the gallery
okay I'm not just about that just go
wrap it up so I can take some questions
Winston thank you for that wonderful
presentation can you hear me okay yeah I
can hear it
great so there were a ton of questions
while you're presenting and we could
sort of narrow them down into just a
couple overall medic questions the first
of those is are these examples that
you're showing self-contained or do they
involve some sort server-side processing
they do require these examples all
involve server-side processing in the
sense that there needs to be an AR
process running so so they don't just
run in the web browser and if you need
to well if you need to do that then
there's other graphical libraries that
are available that that can do it but
they're not they don't give you the full
power of what you can't take you know
these interactions and run them through
your our code and so you don't have as
much flexibility limited to what
typically what these JavaScript
libraries will allow you to do and then
sort of a similar question I guess uh
can you embed these these interactive
graphics and shiny apps into our
markdown documents uh you can in if you
use I think where we've turned an
interactive Docs so you can use them in
interactive our modern documents they
won't work in so so interactive
documents are actually they're actually
are more current
sort of run as shiny apps but your usual
are marketing documents that are just
generate a static HTML webpage those
bills do not support this type of
interactive graphics but again they do
they would support interactive graphics
that are that run completely in the
client in the web browser and there are
various well for those of a better more
advanced users there are there are some
HTML widgets the packages that use HTML
widgets that that allow this and then
another common questions what
visualization packages does shiny work
with to make interactive graphics ok
well so I showed for this for this type
of interactive graphics that I showed so
my purpose here was to talk about things
that where you could use your existing
knowledge of our and our as graphing
packages and then add some interactivity
to them so this is using besar and in
ggplot2
the photograph in packages like lattice
unfortunately we don't support
interactions with lattice at this point
and so for I think for for static
graphics that you could add
interactivity to those are those are the
big ones there are packages that will
generate graphics that are meant to be
displayed in the web browser that might
be based on for example d3 but I at this
point I couldn't tell you a whole lot
about those about which ones work well
with shining and then my last question
or the last question is is this
technology meant to replace Gigi vis or
will Gigi vis one day replace this
technology that's like that is that's a
really good question so this is this is
not meant to replace ggp is Gigi vis is
it's a work that's well we've still got
some work to do on it and it's it will
support much more and what it actually
already does support much more
sophisticated in our
and what I've shown you here but there's
still some more work well is it fair bit
more work to be done on it to really to
get it through to do what we want to do
and this stuff is again meant to take
your existing knowledge of our graphing
packages and and add some interactivity
to them so so in the long term
hopefully digifizz will will supplant
this all this stuff okay well thank you
so much for taking time units it is
quite yeah thanks thank you guys I'm fun